it's no secret that a lot of parents are
taking the brunt of the stress during
this pandemic but we still ask the poll
question about it new cbs news polling
finds that nearly half of parents half
feel exhausted or frustrated and of
course a lot more families can relate to
that but there may be a solution some
moms across america have found a way to
let off a little steam no kids allowed
mega oliver has more
hi nice to meet you on a bitter cold
sunday morning just outside new york
city a group of women all moms many
strangers gathered for their very first
group scream
jessica klein organized a mom screaming
event in her community an opportunity
for parents to come together to vent
two years of a pandemic burden with the
stresses of child care school
disruptions and new variants have left
many parents drained
jessica says over the last two years
she's often felt overwhelmed and
isolated when the pandemic started she
had three under six my house felt narrow
i felt like the walls were caving in on
me and i just felt like
there was no place to go and you had a
six month old on your hip i had a six
month old down my hip i had a
four-year-old and a six-year-old who was
in kindergarten so nobody was in school
and keeping them entertained throughout
the day and while changing diapers
and nursing
was insane nearly 40 percent of moms
responding to a recent survey reported
they are experiencing a negative impact
on their physical and mental health and
many working moms said it's difficult to
balance their children and jobs around
half had to leave or downshift their
careers during the pandemic
as the women gathered on this day hint
of emotions poured out i feel really
guilty and
i don't know the right thing to do a lot
of time i just work in my daughter
i have no time for me i am grateful for
for this opportunity
but even though
um it is a very unique opportunity it
doesn't take away from how lonely
uh it could be damn i feel like i work
so hard all the time and i'm not getting
anywhere finally the time had come to
let it out three
two
one
i joined in for round two
after you let out the first scream how
did it feel
it was just such a sense of relief
and also to be away from my kids for a
little while i love them dearly
and you know i want them to know that
but it is nice to just be able to go and
be in a community of moms it's safe it
offers relief and now these very tired
and very
overwhelmed parents know they're not
alone psychologist lisa demour is a cbs
news contributor she says these
screaming events can be a healthy way to
express and release emotion february is
always a hard time of year in family
life it's the armpit of the school year
under normal conditions this is a hard
time of year
these
conditions plus two years of a pandemic
is extraordinarily difficult jessica
hopes this is just the beginning of mom
gatherings in her community
what are you hoping these moms walked
away with today
i hope that moms walked away with a
sense of self-care even if it's
just for a little bit and a positive
memory that they can bring with them
after this entire
chaos
psychologist lisa demour told us every
parent reaches a point of frustration
and exhaustion but there is a lot of
shame surrounding that she said it's
important to talk about the uglier sides
of parenthood to make parents feel less
alone and ashamed i feel i give these
women so much credit they showed up they
didn't know anybody and then they're
just pouring their hearts and you poured
out something
i had a little bit more to coach and
they all stopped going
but it's important i think what the
story highlights meg is it's important
to take care of yourself as parents
you're taking care of your kids and
you're worried about your family but you
sometimes forget about your own mental
health and your own self-care and that's
really important self-care your
self-care strong contender for most
popular story on facebook today yeah
it's that one i i i prefer not yelling
but just dunking my head in the
back protector in there protect that
voice meg thank you so much